dating we laid everything out they
talked about what they were facing and
in their next response I heard him say
we've not they've not lost their fight
and they don't know how to give up so
make moan make no mistake they are and
we are still in the fight Iowa's like no
other place we adapt we solve and we
excel in very difficult tonight's and
there's no doubt in my mind that we'll
recover as a state and Iowans will
rebound stronger than ever I want to
just recognize the quick actions of our
first responders our city and county
leaders our elected officials of
volunteers and our state agency team
members that the State Emergency
Operations Center it was amazing I had
the Commissioner and the director
traveling with me
as well as yesterday
they would back up I think the stories
and what we saw
but these individuals both at the local
level and at the state level and just
volunteers have been working around the
clock to keep Iowans safe so I really
commend all the individuals on their
immediate responses the seamless
coordination and really the ongoing
collaboration to address this year I'll
give you a little bit about the timeline
and then maybe some questions that we're
hearing on why this flooding is so
significant so on Monday March 12th
we had our initial coordination call
with the National Weather Service by
Wednesday we were meeting and staging
material prepared on Thursday March 14th
I signed a disaster Proclamation for the
state of Iowa and we stood up the SIOC
as of today we have 41 Iowa counties
that are eligible
Iowa individual assistance and state
resources because they've been
designated a disaster County some of the
questions on why the flooding has been
so significant it actually was a perfect
storm
he had record wetness across Nebraska
the worst in a hundred and twenty four
years we had the bomb cycled low
pressure that triggered intense snow and
rain that happened on Thursday increased
runoff because the ground was still
frozen we had extremely low temperatures
and then we rapidly warmed up we have a
lot of unregulated tributaries that
flowed into the Missouri
especially the Platte and the other
rivers in Nebraska we had preliminary
estimates that indicated it was flying
at three hundred thousand cubic feet per
second into the Missouri River and that
caused record flows south of Council
Bluffs that has in reality has
compromised every single levee from from
Council Bluffs all the way down to the
Missouri border so significantly we are
continuing to work with local officials
to assess the flood damage will be
taking additional action in the days and
weeks ahead I've said over and over this
is all hands on deck federal state and
local I have been in contact with the
White House I'll be meeting with vice
president pence later this afternoon
where we'll do a flyover of the
Mississippi Missouri excuse me we're
also monitoring the Mississippi with
with the Missouri and I'll be doing that
with governor Ricketts I have had
Secretary of Agriculture sonny perdue
reach out to me Linda McMahon a small
business administrator has also reached
out we'll be talking to her this
afternoon
Secretary of Transportation and lien
Elaine Chao reached out yesterday or
this morning so we'll be visiting with
her as well as the FEMA acting director
Peter peep Gaynor really our message is
again this is needs to be a coordinated
effort we need to cut through the red
tape we need to eliminate bureaucracy we
need to apply common sense practices we
need to do everything that we can to
shoot for early release release of funds
and support from the federal level
I've asked directly for significant
assistance from the Army Corps of
Engineers to make sure that it's timely
coordinated text technical expertise and
just again to maybe utilize some of the
current maintenance maintenance funding
that can be redirected early release of
emergency relief funding for the US
Department of Transportation for Federal
Highway Administration for our highways
and then of course being in support of
Milazzo
we've seen the loss of stored grain
full of grain this is typically the time
they start to move it and so tremendous
lost there and as well as livestock and
then what do we need to do as farmers
ramped up to put in the new crops for
next year it's it's important also I
have been in constant contact with
governor Ricketts that we look at this
from a regional perspective so that
we're putting in place really the
strategy to address the tremendous
amount of road damage and again
industry at the state level I'll be
meeting with my cabinet to seamlessly
continue response and damage assessments
to lay the groundwork for an aggressive
recovery strategy whether that's
infrastructure with secondary roads that
are in a horrific condition because of
the wet weather and so we'll be
addressing that we've got water and
sewer treatment centers that have been
compromised and impacted we'll be
looking at housing recovery assistant
Main Street businesses recovery and
stability
sorry about the delay alice is gonna be
done coming down the stairs just after
me things are moving fast so even the
even the media release we're about to
give you a little bit outdated so that
was just finished 30 minutes ago
[Music]
cell phones that are turned on let's put
them into silent mode
[Music]
we're seeing that happen to seeing a lot
of coordination and we just nature
you know stay vigilant
she was following me downstairs so I
think the one thing we're waiting on is
an easel we've got we got a visual that
that shows what the tank farm is so for
you guys on camera I'll turn it over to
director Flynn who will give you some
more Thank You governor good morning
from the State Emergency Operations
Center perspective we do have key state
agency partners in to help coordinate
and effectively get resources to where
they're needed we work with the county
emergency managers in each County and
our job is to support them and make sure
they're getting the resources they need
to both respond to and recover from the
incidents that are impacting them as the
governor said seeing this from the air
especially it is truly catastrophic I
saw I flew in 2011 and there is no
comparison between 2011 and now so our
job is as she said to dig in make sure
we're getting the resources to where
they're needed so that Iowans can
recover as quickly as possible thank you
so we'll open it up for questions
yeah and we'll do the same thing but in
the interim joys or continue to work
with their emergency managers and
agencies across the state so that we're
capturing and starting to assess the
damage I have no doubt that we will
qualify for a presidential disaster
declaration we need to have the
information and the assessment in place
to just make sure that we're getting
that documented and they're doing a
really you know good job of that even
with everything that's going on but as I
said earlier we want to see what we can
do to expedite the funding to make sure
that we can get that in place and start
to alleviate some of the you know
concerns and questions that communities
and farmers and Iowans have all across
the state well I I don't want to hear
things like we'll study that for three
years or we're gonna do we have to you
know think about strategically how we
address this and that means you look at
the short-term what we can do that's why
we're bringing in the state agencies
when I talk about just the so that's on
our piece but even from the federal
level let's figure out ways to be
innovative to get this done to attack it
from a six month perspective and then
maybe a long term
what are those tributary what are the in
tiebacks I could never remember that
thank you that was one of the things
that we heard is we met with especially
down in Hamburg so we need to fix those
first and then focus on the levee the
levee structures that have been
compromised or breached so I mean that's
it's going to take some time it's wet
the soil is different in different
places so there's a strategy on how we
attack that but just to also apply you
know some common sense procedures when
we're when we're doing that and moving
forward and let's figure out how we get
it done and not you know in the short
term
well they're there in place and we saw
that actually last spring when we saw
the flooding you know the oh the
monitors that's been too lucky the
gauges are the gauges it's been a long
two days but those have been just
phenomenal and we actually have more
gauges in place than a lot of the other
state that other states do and we've
been purposeful about putting those in
and that's really allows us to do the
modeling that we need and I think that
that was instrumental last year
especially when we were dealing with the
Mississippi and the impact that that
would have on Cedar Rapids in that area
just being prepared with the communities
up and down the area that's that's
impacted by the flow of the Mississippi
so we'll continue monitoring that we
just have a tremendous amount of
flooding even that's happening in state
I mean look at where the 41 counties are
at so we'll also be during those
communities later this week to make sure
that we're understanding what their
needs are what they're dealing with
making sure they're getting the
resources that they need as well I get a
situation report every day from the SIOC
which really is a brief recap of what
the new requests are coming in from
counties across the state what the
anticipated weather is going forward and
what we can how we can continue to be to
be ready so we're all of that it's going
on it typically melts I think a little
slower on the Mississippi side than it
does on the Missouri side so but I just
can't stress enough and people that have
dealt with this before especially along
the Missouri you know this we're in for
the long haul we're just getting started
we really haven't seen the snow melt yet
that will impact it
so and then and just the spring rains
that we're gonna get so what typically
would be handled by the levee system
that's in place because they've been
compromised it's gonna be you know a
difficult could potentially be a
difficult situation all through the
spring and summer know and I you know I
said we're not going to have any trouble
I don't think meeting the requirement
for the federal declaration but they are
still coming in I mean I had a farmer
reached out to me yesterday around the
Hamburg area I mean the amount of grain
that's in the bends and in the elevators
it's just significant I think he'd
talked to ten farmers and they were they
alone had 750 thousand bushels and there
are still bins that are splitting and
dumping and elevators that were full so
you know a lot of those aren't insured
so that's what I talked to sonny Perdue
about we just have to that has to be a
part of the conversation that we have
going forward especially you know
they've taken out loans they're trying
to get ready to put new crop in the
fields and so that's going to have a
significant impact also what we're
dealing with down in the Hamburg area
was brought to our attention the loss of
hogs there were some hog farms down
there and and just with the 10 that they
know they're about 25 thousand you know
get rid of so I mean and that's just
these are just honestly probably some of
the tip of the iceberg of what we're
hearing so so assessments are still
coming in
oh yeah so inception egg is a part of
this also so he's also he has the
opportunity there's some disaster relief
that's available I think through you
from USDA that secretary could do was
one of the reasons he reached out we
just we need to see what it is and then
figure out what's available but for
instance with other disasters that we've
gone through there's public
infrastructure dollars that are
available so that's one component we
will have no trouble and director Lowe
can talk about that if you want some
specifics probably meeting that and then
being creative and innovative how we can
pull together like we did with the
floods of 2011 with a very condensed
timeline because it's set for so long
four months and then they went from the
beginning of the incidents that we
really kudos to them for really getting
that done and in a timely manner so we
could receive funding so there's the
public infrastructure side and then
there's the individual assistance so
that is sometimes a little bit more
difficult to to reach that but I don't
know I mean we saw do you anything to
add to that side of it I will just
quickly say on the public assistance
side from the federal government as a
state we have to reach four point five
million dollars in damages with and
that's roads bridges critical
infrastructure so I don't have a concern
I can't say for sure we've got to gather
the numbers